how did the mcu's favorite witch go from
a sitcom loving superhero to the
multiverse's most dangerous threat and
how does doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness match up with the
wanda we last saw in one division the
marvel cinematic universe's wanda
maximoff has come a long way since first
appearing in a credit stinger for
captain america the winter soldier
before popping up as a secondary
antagonist turned hero in 2015's
adventures age of ultron in the infinity
saga wanda joins the avengers after her
brother pietro dies fighting ultron her
growing pains as a superhero in training
serves as one of the catalysts for tony
stark and steve rogers feud in captain
america civil war and she finds love in
the most unexpected of places in the
mind stone fueled android vision of
course thanos murders vision in avengers
infinity war before snapping wanda and
half the universe out of existence for
five years
with many of the original avengers dead
or off planet after avengers end game
marvel studios has leaned hard on wanda
to provide a through line for phases
four stories so far one division caught
up with the character just after the
infinity saga ends in one of marvel's
most inventive projects showcasing
wanda's power growth as she grieves
vision's death in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness wanda returns as
the scarlet witch more powerful and
scarier than ever mcu fans have long
held suspicions that wanda is among the
universe's most powerful characters
based on both the original comics and
examples from the movies the 2021 disney
plus mini-series one division only
further fueled that notion when she
alters reality within an entire town's
borders turning it into a fictional
sitcom revolving around her wanda's
grief for vision made her personality
less balanced and her powers more
dangerous she steps into even more of a
moral gray area after besting agatha
harkness and acquiring a copy of the
darkhold combining her rare chaos magic
abilities with dark magic forbidden even
to masters of the mystic arts that's the
book of the damned
in one division agatha tells wanda that
the scarlet witch's power surpasses even
the sorcerer's supremes steven strange
is not actually the sorcerer supreme by
the time the new doctor strange movie
starts but he also directly acknowledges
to wanda that she's more powerful than
any avenger still on earth when he tries
to recruit her to help him and america
chavez while wanda acknowledges her
mistakes in holding an entire town
against its will during one division she
dreams of the life she wishes she could
have with her sons more than anything
else by the time doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness starts wanda has
basically lost everything vision is dead
and white vision went missing after
regaining vision's memories at the end
of one division after the incident in
westview wanda does not even have a
reality in which she has her children
the prospect of a new reality with her
children drives her first and foremost
while strange has nightmares concerning
the details of his variance lives across
the universe wanda says her nightmares
begin when she wakes up each morning and
remembers that her chance at having a
family is gone unless she finds another
one in the infinite multiverse you open
the doorway between universes
we don't know who or what will walk
through it wanda uses the dark holds
disturbingly powerful magic to dreamwalk
possessing alternate versions of herself
and send monsters after america chavez
throughout the multiverse wanda's
emboldened usage of the darkhold in her
pursuit of america and strange turns her
and her possessed earth-838 counterpart
into monstrous villains wanda displays
her significantly scaled-up power level
multiple times and warns strange that
her violent destruction of comrtage
constitutes her attempt to be reasonable
wanda actually succeeds in her attempt
to capture america even after bringing
her back to earth 616's darkhold castle
wanda still must fend off desperate
attacks from wong and strange who
dreamwalks into an alternate strange's
corpse america finally uses her portal
opening abilities intentionally sending
the scarlet witch to earth 838 where
that universe's wanda does live happily
with her children at this moment wanda
learns why she can't make this reality
her reality the other universe's billy
and tommy recognize the scarlet witch as
the evil and threatening entity she's
grown into not the loving mother wanda
wishes she could be wanda comes to a
conclusion similar to the one that is
reached at the end of one division but
this time her grief and desperation have
caused significant harm to multiple
universes rather than just one town in a
sudden change wanda uses her magic to
destroy every copy of the darkhold
across every universe in existence and
disappears it's unclear what may happen
to the character in the mcu moving
forward but it seems she finally learns
the lesson she should have after
wandavision she can't use her powers to
force her desired universe into
existence
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]